- What is the church's status
on this public university?
And the answer is it
has no status whatsoever
because it's not connected
in any way, shape, or form
because it's on its own land
that is just nearby to
the public university.
(upbeat music)
There's been a movie franchise
that I've been putting off reacting to
because of all of the theological
and philosophical implications,
so today we're gonna talk about,
"God's Not Dead 3: A
Light in the Darkness,"
with none other than
Michael from Wisecrack.
Thanks so much for being here, Michael.
- I'm so glad to be here.
If ever there is a movie I wanted to watch
and talk about with you,
for whatever reason,
this would be the one.
- All right, well, for better or worse,
let's dig into "God's Not Dead 3."
- Oh, I can't wait.
- We're seeing more and more
protests around the city
since local pastor David Hill
was arrested for contempt of court.
- Hill refused to abide
by a controversial government mandate
to turn over transcripts of
his sermons to city officials.
- If we're looking at this news report
that is potentially a
summary from the Local News,
that is the name of the website.
"Reverend David Hill, pastor
of local St. James Church,
was arrested Monday
after refusing to abide by
a controversial government mandate
for all Hope Springs religious leaders
to turn over their sermons
to government officials for review.
Many are accusing the state
of overstepping its bounds"
Yeah, you think?
- Yeah.
- "claiming they are on
a witch hunt to silence"
To silent?
- Religious leaders.
- To silence religious leaders
is I think what they meant,
"from making political
statements from the pulpit."
- They didn't grammar check
the Local News article.
- I mean, this is why local news is dying.
- I mean, doesn't that
violate some sort of church,
state, religious
- [Devin] Yeah,
- freedom distinction
- a million different things.
So the only thing that this
could possibly be related
to is what's called the Johnson Amendment
which it's not a mandate against
churches being political.
It is that if you
explicitly get into politics
then you potentially lose
your status as a nonprofit.
- Okay. Yeah.
- So factually
everything the church does
would then be taxable.
No one's going to,
like the IRS police
aren't gonna come around
and force you to turn over your sermon.
That's just not a thing.
- Wow. So I've learned a
lot and I've also learned
that there's no fact checker
at the Hope Springs Local News.
- Now a contentious
and heated free speech debate
is threatening to boil over
while the pastor sits in
jail waiting for a ruling.
(melancholic music)
- The fact that Ted McGinley
is in this too is crazy.
(door buzzes)
- Let's go.
- You know, I mean, it's almost like,
and I would never accuse
the filmmaker of this,
they wanted to gin up
the idea that Christians
in America are under attack.
- It's almost like all of
these movies are operating
with that fundamental assumption.
- I don't think that's the case.
I would never accuse
the filmmaker of that.
It's the baggage that
I'm bringing into this
- Yes.
- that they're taking on
a persecution complex.
(melancholic music)
- He looks like worn down by,
presumably his one night
is spent by himself.
- [Rev. Dave] Hey.
- Dude.
- I mean, the conditions that we're seeing
in the jail are so much
better than your average
like accused is going
to be in, in the U.S.
- Well, they probably kept him
in solitary 'cause of the risk he posed.
- [Crowd] Free Reverend
Dave! Free Reverend Dave!
(Crowd chanting "Free Reverend Dave!")
- [Reporter] Reverend,
what do you have to say
about being released today?
- I am grateful to the
court that they recognize
that this mandate was unconstitutional.
(Devin sighs)
- Look, okay.
Is it a mandate?
Is it a subpoena?
Is it something unrelated
that he actually was found
in contempt of court for?
Like, is the church protected
from criminal investigations?
Is it possible that they
might have to disclose things,
you know, related to speech?
This is a really interesting exercise
of the different parts
of the First Amendment.
And I can't wait to see
how they resolve all
of these issues.
- This is more of a human rights issue.
It's about our right to seek truth
and to share that truth with others.
- [Reporter] But considering
your church is associated
with a public university,
how do you define truth exactly?
- Okay. How is this church associated
with a public university?
To the extent that there
is a formally recognized
or formally associated church
with a public university,
that probably doesn't pass muster.
But I gotta know the answer
to that question to be able
to understand anything else
that's going on in this movie.
They'll tell, they'll tell us for sure.
I completely trust them.
(Devin laughs)
- I'm sure.
- Yeah.
- Truth is a person,
the person of Jesus Christ.
It's the one truth above all others.
- What do you have to
say to the people here
who are calling you,
- Jesus Christ is the one truth.
Really?
This guy just can't help himself can he?
- A couple of things here,
not strictly speaking legal,
but I'd like your take on this.
Number one,
the pastor gets outta jail
and the first question
he's presented with is:
- "How do you define truth exactly?"
- Just a totally normal
question for a reporter to ask.
- If only journalists would
corner people and say like,
"Hey, what's your
epistemological framework?"
Or, you know, really getting
to the bottom of this stuff.
- I would be on board with that.
I think that's a great question
to ask people.
- It'd be fun.
I encourage any reporters
watching to start doing that.
- No, it's a really weird thing to ask.
- On top of it,
this is a Christian pastor
somewhere in middle America,
and he says probably
the most anodyne thing
I can possibly imagine a pastor saying.
And it's national news, like,
'this guy can't help himself."
He's talking about religion.
- There's a comment here.
So we're looking at, I think
a fake Facebook stream.
- [Devin] Yeah.
- [Michael] And Brandy Lynn said:
"What would you expect a pastor to say?"
Yes, Brandy.
- [Devin] Thank you.
(Devin laughs)
- Like it's not,
it's not super weird.
- [Commentator #1] Right.
Freedom of worship.
- In places of worship.
But Hadleigh is a state university.
- See and that's the question y'all.
What's the church doing on a state campus
in the first place?
- That is a good question.
- It's a good question.
- As the battle rages on in Hope Springs,
- [Commentator #2] A historic landmark
that has served this community
for over a century and now
they want the church gone.
This is what our country has come to.
- The slow look back.
- The Supreme Court,
especially more recently,
has allowed public funds to
flow to religious organizations,
and especially has carved out exceptions
where there's long-standing traditions.
The court tends to bend over
backwards to find an exception
that says it's not really religious,
it's more about history.
Maybe this church has
been on public grounds
for years and years.
- Yeah.
Well maybe it predates the construction
of the campus around it.
- Maybe.
(glass shatters)
(alarm rings)
- What was that?
- [Rev. Jude] I don't know.
(alarm continues)
- [Rev. Dave] Hey! Hey!
- [Rev. Jude] David!
- [Rev. Dave] Get back here!
- [Rev. Jude] David, no!
(alarm continues)
(melancholic piano music)
- This looks like
relatively petty vandalism.
You got a kid who has spray
painted a single X on the sign
and he has thrown a brick
through the window of a church.
This appears to be religiously motivated.
So there is technically a
federal anti-hate crime law
that does make it a federal crime to
destroy a religious property
on the basis of religion.
(object explodes)
(alarm rings)
- Are we meant to believe the rock goes
through the window and then
magically hits the valve
on a gas pipe that's connected to nothing?
I mean, so here's one question.
The person, the young
man, college student,
- Yes.
- presumably baseball player
who threw the brick through the window,
- right?
- Right.
Right.
- has inadvertently
presumably killed a man.
- [Devin] Yes.
- Would it be easy to get
him on murder for that?
- No.
- Okay.
Within the pantheon of
homicide, you have, you know
intentional murders where I literally
specifically intend to kill you.
- Yeah.
- Then you have things like manslaughter.
Negligent homicide where someone dies
in the course of generally
something that is reckless
or inherently dangerous.
There's the felony
murder rule where you are
committing an inherently dangerous crime
and during the commission
of that crime, someone dies.
You are guilty of
- Yeah.
- first degree murder
because you did something
that you should have
known would kill someone.
Here he has thrown a
brick through window and
through a Rube Goldberg series of events
an explosive light bulb went off
that combusted the rest of the gas.
This kid doesn't have the
specific intent necessary
for murder
- Yeah.
- or even the kind of negligence
that would be necessary
for a manslaughter.
The law looks to what your intent was
in determining your level
of culpability or guilt.
I do wonder though,
could his next of kin,
the estate of Jude,
could they sue the
manufacturer of the light bulb
or the manufacturer of the gas valve?
I mean, seemed to be some
major manufacturing defects
that led to this Rube Goldberg of death.
- Yes. Also seems like poor maintenance
on behalf of St. James Church.
- If I was going to sue someone
on behalf of Jude or Jude's Estate,
I would probably sue the
light bulb manufacturer.
I'd probably sue the
gas valve manufacturer.
church to get recompense
for this person that has died.
- This is absurd.
They can just take the church from us.
I mean, don't we own this land?
- [Josh] Yes.
- So how is this legal?
- Eminent domain.
I studied property law
a bit in grad school.
As I understand it
the state gave all public
universities complete autonomy
over eminent domain.
- Can we study it a bit?
- Oh no.
- Just a bit of property
law in grad school.
- Wow. As one does.
Okay. So we finally have an answer.
What is the church's status
on this public university?
And the answer is it
has no status whatsoever
because it's not connected
in any way, shape, or form
because it's on its own
land that is just nearby
to the public university.
The church owns the land.
This doesn't involve the
First Amendment in any way.
Because the church owns this land,
the public university
is going to try to use
what's called eminent
domain where, you know,
a government entity can take over land
to repurpose it for some other use.
- Yeah. That's like when
houses get knocked down
to build a new freeway.
- Exactly right. Exactly right.
Now it is the case that sometimes
churches have been
subject to public domain.
And it is also the case that
sometimes public universities
have more or less the power
to engage in eminent domain.
The private entity is entitled
to the fair market value
of the property that has been taken.
If the university had
a good faith, you know,
non anti-religious reason for
taking over this property,
then it could probably do so.
(Pearce sighs)
- Dad's church.
- You can hardly even recognize it.
- Hey look, this is a property law case.
It's not really my thing.
- [Rev. Dave] Pearce, you're
a social justice attorney.
- Is that a thing?
- Theoretically, there
are civil rights lawyers.
Social justice attorney?
I've never heard that term before.
- Okay. Yeah, that's what I was wondering.
- You would want someone who
specializes in property law.
- Yeah.
- Property law is very complex.
There's a lot of ins and outs.
You would want someone
who has that built-in
institutional knowledge.
You would definitely
not wanna hire this guy.
- Well that's the classic
movie move, right?
That someone knows a lawyer,
they don't specify what their area is,
- Yes.
- And they're magically able
to do the thing.
- Of course. Of course.
Now I'm able to do that.
- Yeah.
- But other people maybe not.
- Let me get this straight.
You drive all the way up here,
you don't even call.
Were you afraid I'd say no?
- I didn't even know what
you'd say to be honest.
Look, I have a little money.
- I don't want your money.
This is a legit offer.
Thing goes to trial,
jury will probably give you
half that amount. Less even.
Money aside,
these things always get messy.
- He just established
he doesn't know anything
about property law,
but he's willing to opine
that this is a good offer.
You should take it.
The jury might give you half of that, so.
- Well, so for trial you're risking that
and you're paying for representation, so.
- Yes.
- Okay.
- Oh,
If you go to trial,
you're going to have to pay your attorney.
It's very rare that
you get attorney's fees
from the other side.
- Yeah.
So you might spend hundreds of thousands
of dollars to get less
than hundreds of thousands
of dollars back in an
increased amount of money.
- God called me to fight.
I'm gonna fight.
- God calls you, you call me.
- God called me to fight is,
has historically not worked out well.
- There's, you know, in the New Testament
we refer to Christ as the Prince of Peace.
So you could also take that route.
There's like, "turn the other cheek."
There's a lot of evidence
that maybe the move isn't to do a holy war
but whatever Reverend Dave
thinks he needs to do.
- [Pearce] Let me know.
- [Rev. Dave] Yeah.
- [Pearce] What, what's going on?
- [Rev. Dave] They won't stop.
Excuse me. Excuse me.
Hey! Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa!
Stop, stop!
- I need you on the other
side of the tape, sir.
- I'm the pastor of this church.
- Well that may be, but it's not safe.
- It's okay. I'm his attorney.
- Congratulations and I'm a Mets fan.
(Devin and Michael laugh)
- What?
- That's a great line. I like that.
- Hey buddy, I have a demo permit.
- You got a permit to wreck
the church on a Sunday. Really?
- Yeah. What can I say?
Signed by the president of the university.
- [Michael] Wait.
- Okay.
- I don't think the president
of a university's ever gonna be able
to sign off on a demo permit.
There's been absolutely no time
for the eminent domain process
to have worked at this point.
Unless there is some ordinance that says
if there is a burned down building
it just has to be demolished.
And that would have no effect
on the eminent domain thing
but have no effect on the
church's ability to rebuild.
This is presumably I think
we have to believe it's
because this church is gonna
fall down and kill someone.
- Yeah. And it looks like it's going to.
(choir singing)
- Your Honor, I am so sorry but
- Do not do this.
This is a hundred percent improper.
- in the middle of mass.
- I'm aware.
It's, it's very timely.
It involves the church.
- I have a signed injunction
from Judge Pascual that says, eh,
you can read it yourself.
Cease and desist.
- If you talk to the judge
without opposing counsel present
generally that is a gross violation
of both court rules and ethics rules.
That's an ex parte communication.
So you can't do stuff
like this where you
talk to the judge alone
let alone on Sunday in a
church in a private setting.
All of that's improper.
Now there is a more fundamental problem
if you can even believe it
which is that there isn't a lawsuit here.
Judges and lawyers,
it's not like you can
just find a random judge
on the street and say, "Hey,
write an injunction for me."
Like there are limited situations where
you can get emergency ex parte relief.
But even that takes 48 hours usually.
Oh. And,
(Devin laughs)
so an injunction is the thing that you get
at the end of a case.
It is the,
- [Michael] Oh,
the final remedy that stops
or forces someone to do something.
- Man, now I have to find
a new film series to learn
about the law from.
- Guess so
- Barbara. We appreciate it.
It's very courteous.
I get it.
It's a prime piece of land.
You know what I'd do if it were me?
I'd put in a big student center
with a fancy coffee shop.
The kids would love it.
I mean, to me that's more
valuable than a dusty old church.
No offense.
But he knows how I feel about it.
Here's the problem, what you're doing,
it's against the law.
'Cause eminent domain
doesn't automatically apply
just because you guys
don't like his church.
So here's my counter.
Withdraw your claim or we sue.
- Whoa. A lawsuit over eminent domain.
- We're done.
- He's already laid the foundation
for why eminent domain
would apply in this case.
The school is theoretically
not seizing this property
because of anti-religious furor
because they don't like the church.
They're doing it because they
want to expand the campus.
So it's a question of valuation.
Did they fairly compensate the church
for the land that they took?
- Josh you're a smart kid.
Why'd you give up on law school?
- I wouldn't say I gave up on it.
Once I spent time on a college campus
I realized there was a real need there.
You know, ministry is just
another way for me to serve.
- What kind of law were you studying?
- Same as you.
Civil rights, social justice.
- Really? 'Cause you don't
strike me as a liberal.
- Did he go to law school or not?
- Do you think that your
religious beliefs get
in the way of real social change?
- No, my, my beliefs are
the foundation of change.
The belief that every human
is made in the image of God.
I mean Jesus was the ultimate
social justice warrior.
He said the lives of children mattered
and regarded women with honor and dignity
in a cultural moment
where a woman's testimony
wasn't even permissible in a court of law.
- Well I've been doing this a long time
and I wish I'd seen those words put
into action more often.
- Yeah, me too.
But we're all responsible for our part.
But it's grace and then justice.
- [Rev. Dave] Amen. Let's say grace.
- He just wants eat his pizza
'cause cool guys love pizza.
I like what Josh admits here,
but it's confusing, right?
'Cause he calls Jesus the
original social justice warrior.
- But I have to wonder who that line
in this movie is geared for.
Because the people I think
that enjoy these movies probably chafe
at the term social justice warrior
and to characterize Jesus
as a social justice warrior,
the first social justice warrior,
- Yeah.
- seems like it's going to rub the people
that watch this movie the wrong way.
- So it's interesting to have
this like internal critique
within the film
'cause the films again are
representing this world
where it seems like
Christianity is about like laws,
institutions codifying beliefs
in the sort of objective way.
And you have Cool Guy Josh saying no
it's about like living a life
of grace and justice and
all this sort of stuff, so.
I mean, like you said, why is it there?
- At the same time, I think
it's the one little morsel
of an interesting read on
the function of religion.
- We condemn the hateful actions
of Adam Richardson in the
strongest possible terms.
We've taken the immediate
steps to expel Mr. Richardson
and we have encouraged
the state to prosecute him
to the fullest extent of the law.
- Okay.
- Hmm.
- They have no power to do any of that.
The church is on its own property.
That's why they had to try to take it
in the first place for
through eminent domain.
And then you can't make a recommendation
to the prosecutor to prosecute someone.
Like you're just a stranger
to this whole thing.
- Well it's like now
that it's convenient to him, he's like,
"yes, the church
which we are a part of that
we own 'cause the university
and the church coexist
in a symbiotic way."
- You're expelled get off the
campus that you're not on.
- Yeah.
- Ah!
- Not good.
Yeah. And I like how they
use that to make them look
like the good guys for a second.
But again, weird overlapping spheres.
- Man.
- I'm so sorry.
(Adam cries)
About Jude, I am so sorry.
- I am withdrawing my
lawsuit against the school.
- He's dropping the charges.
- No, you don't get to do that.
The state prosecutes someone.
The district attorney
will decide whether to
continue prosecuting someone or not.
A victim, even,
and he's a tangentially related victim.
Yeah. They don't get to decide
whether charges are dropped or not.
- Yeah. It seems like the
logic he's using there is like
if someone comes into my
house and kills my friend
I can be like, "no, no, it's my house"
- [Devin] Yeah.
- "so I'd like to drop the charges."
- "Yeah, no, just don't prosecute him."
"I have forgiven him."
"He can go free now."
- We just ended up where
we were in the beginning.
We took a long journey to get
to him saying like,
"Fine, take the church."
- This is the most self-defeating movie
I think I've ever watched.
He just used legal services
of his cool guy brother
for months with no
compensation whatsoever.
He's dropped his entire
- Yeah.
- legal practice to prosecute this thing.
- That's the real victim
is Cool Guy Brother.
(Devin laughs)
- Okay. So now we have to
give this movie a grade
for legal realism.
(upbeat music)
It just occurred to me that
they haven't resolved any
of the First Amendment issues at all.
- I forgot that that's
what this movie was about.
- They did use some legal terms correctly.
Eventually we did learn
that eminent domain was the
thing that they had to use.
Other than that, a lot of inaccuracies.
Never talk to the judge outside
of the court proceedings.
I'm gonna give this one a solid D,
room for improvement.
- That's not bad.
You give someone a D
they still have a chance in the class.
- They still pass. They still pass.
Yeah. We're giving a passing grade just
so we never have to watch it again.
If you wanna see Michael take
on the philosophical aspects
of this movie to the
extent that there are any,
check out our collaboration over here.
If you wanna see more Legal
Eagle, check out this video
over here or I'll see you in court.